Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David P I've been
talking about in the midst of the Chick-Fil-A
fiasco, I've never been to a Chick fil A,
and I said maybe I'll go to one this weekend
when I'm going to be out in Long Island.
They have a bunch of Chick fil A's there.
But when I looked at, like their breaded
chicken sandwich, the ingredients looked so
toxic that maybe I'd go with like the grilled
and a bunch of people wrote to me and here's
a voicemail saying, David, don't get don't
get that. That's not the right item to get.
Speaker 2: He wrote it down on Jersey. I hear
you're thinking of going to Chick-Fil-A. Yeah. And
you say you want to give me grilled chicken? David
No. Like restaurants have certain items on their
menu just for people like you. Like when you go to
a steakhouse, they have salads, but the salads
aren't any good. It's just for people that are
in the group that don't they don't need or don't
want a steak. But the salad is no good. Just like
you go to a seafood restaurant, like they have
meatballs on the menu, but you don't get meatballs
at the seafood place. Truth is on the menu for
people that don't like seafood. True. Those are.
Why are you in a secret place? You don't go
to Chick-Fil-A and get the grilled chicken,
Dave. You have to get the Chick-Fil-A original
chicken sandwich. I recommend no pickles because
they're these cheap little. They're not.
Speaker 1: Well, other people said
definitely get the pickles.
Speaker 2: A real quality pickles so
you can get no pickles. Add lettuce and tomato,
and you gotta eat the waffle fries. David, because
waffle fries have more surface area. So. Really?
Speaker 1: All right, I get the point. Listen, I,
I tend to agree, like I get the sandwich Chick fil
A is known for is the breaded chicken sandwich.
The thing about it is you look at I just was
cruising the website. You look at the ingredients,
it's like rib meat injected with water. I don't
even really know what part of the chicken the
rib meat is. I had to look it up and it's like
some connective tissue between something in it.
It's not even a part of the chicken I was familiar
with. It sounds really toxic. It really does. But
I do agree that if I'm going to do the Chick fil
A thing, I should probably just get the classic
the classic sandwich. So I don't know if it'll
end up happening. I will report back if it does
and we'll kind of go from there. On today's
bonus show, we will talk about Ken Paxton,
the attorney general of Texas, being impeached. We
will talk about how in Minnesota, cannabis users
can't own firearms despite a new law. And we will
talk about the two year prison sentence given to
the woman who threatened Nancy Pelosi with hanging
during the Trump riots. All of those stories and
more on today's bonus show. Don't miss the bonus
show. Sign up at join Pacman dot com. It will be
a fantastic day for everyone. Otherwise,
we'll see you back here tomorrow, Friday.